good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday i hope everyone's having an
amazing beautiful sunny bright
positive day yes so far so good the sun
is shining i look like a tick tocker
you do what's up counts don't i look
like you look like a kid
you know honestly i think i could be
friends with snitch the this is part of
our overall you know 2021 q1 strategy
just trying to target younger
demographics and so you're dressing like
a young person today and i think the
young people will respond
thank you young people we see each other
what are you doing to attract a new
demographic today
um i don't know the tick tock i spoke so
highly about yesterday like really over
performed on tick tock
i think because i like made it such a
stink on the show like so many people
went from
podcast app to tick tock to check it out
and it did really well and i'm really
proud of myself and i also
did another tick tock yesterday that is
pertinent to today's show because
i know i spoke a while about how i was
going to stop buying viral makeup from
tiktok because these products go viral i
buy them
and they just like never work on me and
they don't look half as good as they do
on other people
but i could not resist getting the kvd
vegan
um good apple balm foundation it's like
this new type of foundation it's not
liquid it's a bomb i don't know
i got it yesterday i made a couple tick
tocks i'm wearing it today i don't know
if anyone can notice
but i'm really pleased with my not only
my content but my skin today
i've heard it doesn't wear very well so
we'll see how what happens at the end
like over time yeah like separates gets
a little oily i mean i do have dry skin
so
that's not a problem for me and it could
stand to look like a little you know
glowy
totally well you look super glowy and
your skin does look really good so
whatever you're doing keep doing it
thank you for you know pulling in the
gen z
yes and i think we're both doing our
part we both have a middle part i i
really don't want to be one of those old
people who like harps on that trend
because like
i find it to be lame lame and just like
you're showing your age
and like i don't know who needs to hear
this but like joking about your age is
not a personality trait like it's never
has been it never will be it does make
you interesting just like
be confident in who you are sorry
totally age with power like normal would
say
yeah age with power like normal would
say and also i bought a norma top
yesterday
norma sells on amazon prime sickening
sickening so i got a couple normatops
yesterday um
i just like need clothes i get weird
like i just farted and it became spring
and it's like what the [ __ ] so i have
like nothing to wear all i have is
turtlenecks
no totally also speaking of amazon prime
you did a patreon video yesterday
that is really just like influencing
everyone including myself claude did a
video of
her best amazon finds like the products
that she's bought on amazon that have
changed her life made her life easier
like things you need to get
i was influenced to buy a number of
things what'd you get i'm the mini
chopper of course
literally yesterday i made taco meat
what is normally like 30 minutes
i chopped garlic and onion and then i
browned the meat sauce and everything uh
10 minutes like the chopper changed my
[ __ ] life well and also the video
that i put up on patreon before yours
i'm using a garlic mincer that's like
this mechanical
thing i know that where my hands are
like breaking so to go from that mincer
which i thought was like
you know the pinnacle of invention no to
your chopper
literally you press a button it's the
craziest thing like i bought it
a hundred percent sure it wasn't gonna
work i just knew that they have these
like
electric choppers so i bought the
cheapest one just in case it didn't work
and it's literally the best thing that
it's like a mini food processor and when
i'm chopping a lot of things i do use my
food processor but why would i make
another dish
where i don't have to no it's the best
so i was influenced to buy that
influenced to buy the heated cur eyelash
curler
okay it's good yeah and influence to get
those
clips every time i finally like get the
right hair clips like the trends change
and now there's a new clip
i know um but so yeah on our patreon i
think it was it ended up like maybe 15
of my favorite things from amazon
so patreon.com slash morning toast for
that fun little vlog and people seem to
like it so jackie's gonna do one i'm
gonna do one next month i'm really
excited i've been going through
my amazon purchases i actually like buy
some really crazy [ __ ]
that works well your husband is also
like gadget
obsessed i'm gonna i'm yours is gonna be
really interesting i'm gonna bring him
into the video because i think he'll
have a lot to offer the people like he
brought those led lights into our life
and literally i um i've posted the link
to them on my
instagram so many times and then i look
at like the number of times it was
clicked and ordered and it's insane
also um zach like your husband could
have like a gadget channel he could be
like a tech youtuber he could be like an
unboxer and it should literally like his
channel should be called gadgets and
gizmos of plenty no he really could like
in a parallel universe
right he's like a youtuber who does like
sneakers and gadgets no no
like totally like that little bedroom in
your house that is like converted into
like his space for his sneakers
it's like maurice's like invention
studios yeah no but it's like
it's like his office beauty and the
beast that is he would film in there
yeah no it is his office and it's also
like gadget heaven
excuse me oh my god gadgets and gizmos
of plenty yes
exactly so that will be coming soon head
over to patreon.com
the morning toast i just want to shout
out really quickly to all the jewish
toasters
who are dealing with what i'm dealing
with right now which is not only like
carb withdrawal but it's the
unbearable constipation from matzo like
literally eating cardboard like
it is so torturous but like yesterday i
was so
hungry and i just could not find
anything to eat so i had like
like two huge pieces of matzah and then
i'm like i haven't [ __ ] today oh yeah
that's right and then i also had lots of
crackers with my taco meat for dinner
like
it's just like a lot of
what's the um the word with a bee
that like it like blocks your stomach
like it's a lot of
brown no it's like bran
no that blocks your stomach no like it's
like
does anyone know i don't even know what
you're like trying to say
like okay okay let me try to explain
it's like a word that starts with b
that like i'm not sure what the word
like actually means that's the problem i
can't explain
it you don't know the wording you don't
know
no yes but i just know it's like a b and
it's like when like your stomach
is like completely bound up like with
like
starch do you know what the [ __ ] is
not really yeah maybe someone is
shouting it into their
podcast podcast it's like whatever
that's what i'm feeling like lots of
what's the word like whatever i'm like
clogged up and i know a lot of people
are too because the matz is the devil um
i'm so sorry to hear that i had a matzo
pizza last night it was good to be
honest like i was already feeling
constipated before passover
i'm not i guess i'm just like not having
enough fiber you should add a supplement
to your daily routine i know but then
it's just like one more job for me you
know and i'm a girl with no job so
that's not gonna happen so you can't
have a supplement
unfortunately um well no my mata pizza
was pretty good
and yeah passover's tough and it's
always like you want to use it
as a reason to like do no carbs yeah
okay i can't have bread
i'll cut out the other carbs too maybe
lose a few lbs on this journey
not what's happened i literally eat a
coconut macaroon every 30 minutes
i hate coconut macaroons they are a
passover
delicacy and i [ __ ] hate them dude
you're the one that comes in the can
i have all of them because i hosted a
seder like i ordered macaroons people
brought macaroons i
bought macaroons i have every kind of
macaroon chocolate covered like
everything i have macaroons that are the
ones from the can that are
personally my favorite then i also have
like i got from magnolia bakery you know
they do kosher for passover treats
they have chocolate covered matzah which
was sold out by the time that got there
but they have fresh macaroons and
chocolate covered macaroons and it's
like literal
shredded coconut i love it's like that's
really one of the privileges of living
in new york since
such like a jewish town if you go to a
majority of restaurants
in the bread basket and ask for matzah
they'll have it that's so sweet
i know so that's something we definitely
like take for granted like living in new
york um
it's really nice that is nice i also
haven't been to a restaurant like since
passover but
i'll try i have two quick things to say
please do the first is that yesterday
there was a
true hollywood story marathon on e that
i
watched i watched the um spice girls one
the sex and the city one and then first
half of the clueless one which really
wasn't good i don't think there was just
like enough material there for clueless
you know
yeah um but first of all i learned so
much like because
spice girl's like i was really really
young i didn't know a lot about like the
salaciousness of it all like especially
what mel b went through with eddie
murphy like there was this whole thing
where he like literally denied that he
was the father of their baby and like
wouldn't pay child support
it was like super messy in public um and
i didn't realize that jerry was the one
who really broke up the group
first what'd you think i was just so
young like i was just like spice girls
are here and then they're not here like
i wasn't looking at the blogs you know
who was the zane
you know it was crazy um and then the
sexy the city one was
really really interesting they kind of
they really captured the show as like a
cultural phenomenon
but also what i found to be so
interesting was like how all the women
got to
like for me it was like i didn't know
any of them before and they all just got
lucky and got this role but they were
all like really esteemed actresses
especially cynthia nixon like
who was like one of the first people
ever to be on two broadway shows at once
like she would run from theater to
theater
during intermission wow yeah like so i
just learned a lot and then towards the
end of the day they started playing like
the newer ones remember when they did a
resurgence and my god those new ones
were terrible like
just comparing that to the old ones um
even i watched the kim one again and i
love it and i cry every time they talk
about alice johnson and i just love it
it's really not that well done compared
to the other ones used to be two hours
long like this
the sex of the city one was so in-depth
and it's like they really have this
amazing franchise like eat your
hollywood story is so recognizable
and people are obsessed with
documentaries these days like i can't
believe he hasn't taken more advantage
of that
i think they tried they stunk it up like
the kim one did no service
the narrator was giving me like major
like emily and paris
social media vibes you know like not
only kim's social media like
it was so robotic and like stupid and
i was like i can't believe i thought
this was good when it was on and it
really took me seeing some of the best
work
from like the early 2000s and comparing
it to the one they did last year and
it's just
it didn't cut it do you think that it's
because in the ones from the early 2000s
like one
you didn't know a lot of that backstory
and two there wasn't social media at the
time so even if you were older and were
able to keep up like you wouldn't have
known the ins and outs
whereas today we know everything about
our favorite celebrities and
especially kim kardashian there's
nothing that e true hollywood story
could tell you that you don't already
know
fine that's a fair point but i wasn't
upset with the kim one for not telling
me things i didn't know it was just like
such low production value you know okay
like it was just shitty
and yeah i stand by what i said i i hear
and it could have been way longer they
just kept skipping like then she
launched kkw beauty then she got alice
marie
like what happened between like yeah
slow down because there used to be two
hours and now it was one hour
yeah so i just think like if anyone at e
is listening like
put more money resources into revamping
the each hollywood franchise
it could really revitalize your network
which desperately needs it yeah
i think that's a that's a very fair
assessment and then the second thing i
wanted to say was yesterday was just
like such a busy day for me work-wise
and i'm really now
working on um you know putting the
wheels in motion for my next tour
it won't be for a while it'll be at the
end of the year but you know you got to
book dates and cities and i just feel
like so much has changed
within our country um like people moved
out of big cities and like i just don't
know where to go you know i feel like
i'm starting from scratch so
i just wanted to put a psa out there
like if you want to come see me on tour
can you just like send me a message and
like tell me where you live and like
where you'd like me to come just so i
can get some like
if you start to see some similarities in
the answers you could
i'm like i feel like i'm about to put
together um remember like when you're in
college and you have to use like web
monkey surveys like i'm gonna [ __ ]
put one together just so i can
like where are the people where did
everyone go yeah i don't know you'll
find out
so please just like speak up love to see
it
thanks um how was your day my day was
really good honestly i thought
yesterday's episode of the toast was so
funny i was thinking about it all day
long just
laughing out loud myself like so many
parts first
um like the thing with the dressing
rooms and then my outfit from the day
before and
obviously the krispy kreme ceo like
there was just so many funny moments
and it really carried me through the day
and i also just feel like it was just a
great slice of toast
yeah also i'm so glad you brought that
up just to update everyone from
yesterday we have heard from the krispy
kreme team
we have um a delivery schedule for next
week after after passover
because somebody dm and they were like i
was literally panicking listening to
today's episode because i know you
didn't realize that it's passover like
if you guys did get a delivery
you wouldn't be able to eat them so the
second they reached out i told jackie
like make sure they know to deliver them
after passover
next week hopefully our box of original
glaze will be arriving
and i'm definitely interested in doing a
mukbang are you
always always i love just eating on
camera yeah
call me trisha paytas can't wait
other than that bruce got checked up
from his post neutering oh that's good
everything's looking good on the bruce
front thank god um
and yeah just getting back into the
swing of things you know yeah no it's
gonna be a busy week but you know what
hustle hustle hustle meetings meetings
meetings i also had to read like all
night last night because i finished the
book for the redheads
and we are recording today i'm very
excited if you have questions about the
book or you know any other book that you
saw me read this month
just questions about books in general
for me and the gals email us
the redheadsbookclub gmail.com fabulous
we love to see it i heard the book is
causing quite a stir amongst the
community
you did hear that lots of people having
lots of thoughts yeah no
it's it's extremely interesting book i'm
really excited to talk about it
um so yeah i think i think with that
yeah no i i agree off our chests we can
get into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and you might have noticed this
sickening plant behind me or as we like
to call it
plant nick plant oh sorry mick platt
um and it's very appropriate that
today's episode is brought to you by
bloomscape which is where we got our
mcplant
it's been a long winter stuck indoors
but warmer days are almost here
say it with us spring is coming so get
ready to shake off the winter gloom
throw open your front door
back door any door will do let's get
outside and if your home isn't quite the
oasis you've always envisioned
you gotta check out bloomscape they make
it easy to grow the lush springtime
retreat of your dreams also the book
that i just read um
it ends with us she's like obsessed with
gardening and opens her own spoiler
alert flores shop
and it kind of made me like want to like
you know get into gardening like the way
she described it like so stunningly
beautiful yes i live in an apartment
but it's definitely on my list of to to
to do no and bloomscape will get you
there
they deliver healthy plants right to
your door plus all the grow how you need
to help them thrive
find the plants perfect for your space
whether you've got tons of light or
hardly any
thousands of people have already
upgraded their spaces with beautiful
indoor plants from lundscape
i am one of them in my home and office
and now bloomscape is taking it outside
with their new outdoor bloom kits so if
you're lucky enough to have an outdoor
space
you can also have like a real garden um
so
this plant is the same one i have in my
home it's super easy to take care of it
requires very little maintenance and it
really spruces
up livens up the space yeah literally
there's life in the space
the new outdoor bloom kits from
bloomscape are exactly what we all need
right now
it's the easiest most convenient way to
get growing you can shop a variety of
young plants accessories tools and
supplies everything you need to get your
patio
or porch springtime ready bloomscape's
plant-it
patented shipping technology makes them
one of the few who can deliver happy
healthy plants of all sizes across the
u.s
and bloomscape will ship at the perfect
time to arrive after the last winter
frost so your plants can grow healthy
and strong their kits are super
customizable you can mix and match sizes
and colors
and since no two plants are alike
bloomscape makes it easy to filter
plants
by how much light or attention they need
bloom kits come with a mix of annual
plants suited for your environment
complementary colors and needs so
everything grows in harmony
if you want to get 15 off your plant
order of a hundred dollars or more
use the promo code toast at
bloomscape.com
that's 15 off plant orders of a hundred
dollars or more
at bloomscape.com promo code
toast love it okay let's get into our
first story that is just so weird
okay rachel bilson is spilling the tea
on her interesting interaction with her
former
classmate and fellow hollywood star rami
malik
this is really weird yeah while speaking
on dak shepard and monica padman's
armchair expert podcast
new podcaster rachel bilson opened up
about the time the oscar winner
rami malek asked her to delete their
high school photo off of instagram
for a refresher they went to high school
together and she posted and they were
like friends
yeah she says that they were friends she
posted a throwback image of her and rami
elated to be in new york city when they
were teenagers at the time she commented
on the fashion and wrote in the caption
hey at rami malek where did you get that
gold chain
hashtag tbt hashtag oscar worthy
don't forget the little people so this
was when like there were so much oscar
buzz for him as freddie mercury and like
he might have even just one so he was
like really in the news and she was just
like hopping on the bandwagon yeah she
said remy was a good friend of mine we
were in the same crew in high school
i think oh sorry rob we were in the same
career in high school we did the
crucible together senior year
we were the leads in it together all
these things talking about how cute
they were friends obviously he got super
famous and he's always been extremely
talented even in high school
i had posted a throwback of us from our
senior trip to new york we're super
nerdy just the dorkiest picture of the
both of us but i throw it up because
it's funny and i think it's so important
to be able to make fun of yourself
but after sharing the image she said
that rami reached out to her directly
however it wasn't what she expected she
recalled
i don't usually check my dms on my
instagram maybe a week goes by and i
actually look and i have a message from
romney
but it wasn't like hey how are you it
was straight to
i would really appreciate if you take
that down i'm a really private person
she was like oh [ __ ] okay still central
she said i got really hot and started
sweating i'm all nervous like oh god
what did i do he was a really good
friend it's a funny picture you know i
don't take myself that seriously
according to rachel he just didn't like
the picture of himself
she's friends with his stylist and
stylist was like well it's not a great
picture of him
um and so kids here's the thing i'm
struggling
between like really relating to someone
who doesn't like a photo of himself but
like from high school like i just feel
like at that point
as adults like we let go of our high
school insecurities i don't know i feel
bad for rachel cause like
he could have been nicer and but like
ronnie malik like
is weird like that's like his whole
brand he's like a weirdo mr robot you
know
so like i don't know this whole story
just like makes me uncomfortable for
literally everyone is so uncomfortable
but my question is like
she was famous first and like she became
a huge star when she was a teenager
yeah for like after high school for a
long time like were they friends then
you know because she sort of jumps from
high school and then romney's this big
star it's like what about the time that
you were a big star right so maybe like
romney's like holding harboring some
resentment from like
rachel getting really famous on the oc
etc and like not
you know remembering the little people
and now that it's romney who's made it
big
rachel is like you know being left in
the dust
yeah and she's like don't forget the
little people that was a hashtag and
it's like but you're not little people
you're summer roberts
also i know rachel bilson like has a
huge pit right now because this has now
became a huge story
which is like the last thing rami malik
wanted
so like i and i know she diminished she
was probably just like you know you're
on a podcast you're sharing a story you
forget like the implications of it
and now it's like all over e news and i
have a pit for her i really do because i
think she's probably a really nice girl
100 i have a pit for her like that is
just
the worst feeling ever like i
understand why she posted the photo i
understand why she felt awkward i
understand why she still feels awkward
i don't know if the friendship can
survive this i really don't the thing is
is that i don't think there was a
friendship to survive
yeah it's it's abundantly clear that
these two are just not on the same page
but i guess like you learned something
new every day rami malik and summer
roberts went to high school together
yes and in reading this story i learned
something else new about the high school
that they went to
two other famous people went there high
school um
notre dame high school two other people
went there
and have a photo together from their
time there catherine mcphee and meghan
markle
shut up i know and then i clicked on the
photo look at this photo
they both look exactly the same and this
is like when they were in like a theater
program together there see that we have
to post it to our instagram but also
that
that actually really tracks because
after the oprah interview david foster
and katherine mcphee were spotted out
having dinner
with the royals harry and megan so of
course they knew each other from high
school yeah that's actually so sweet i'm
happy megan has like a friend you know
like a long time friend and katherine
mcphee is not thirsty no and that's a
really great
duo oh my god that's crazy that's just
like erin foster's like
so close to meghan markle and like i
know aaron foster like she wrote her and
sarah like wrote something on my book so
like
i am like three degrees of separation
away from meghan markle
not to make it about me but here you go
making it about thing
so just some interesting high school
factoids and what is yeah i was gonna
say where is notre dame high school i
believe that it's in california
oh that makes sense yeah and it just
like turns out
fabulous famous people that's also like
marymount i think that school is in
california that's where the kardashians
went and that's also where olivia jade
and her sister went
yeah but i think that school like turns
out famous people because it's like
the children of famous people who are
the children of like wealthy people
wealthy orphans who wind up being
wealthy and or famous themselves
that's interesting yeah that's fair so
that's the coincidence yeah
is notre dame like a performing arts
school they obviously have an incredible
performing arts program i'm sorry i
didn't study about the school
before i came up to the show okay i was
just wondering sorry um
but definitely do some research and find
out maybe that's where you should have
gone
by the way if i could redo my life over
i know i really do have no regrets no
regrets no regrets
but the fact that i never like was in
performing arts i wrote about this a lot
in my book like
it's one of my biggest regrets like even
in my like okay i like my school so i
don't wish i went to a different school
but like the fact that i was never gonna
play and i wasn't in the choir for more
than 35 seconds like
that is like a huge letdown for me
because like when in my life am i gonna
be able to express myself in that way
yeah well and i'm really gonna encourage
my children to like follow their
passions
here and now you get to express yourself
every day i know but i get in trouble
when i sing so
that's true but you know you have to
fight for your passions i know it's just
um
it's just one of my like my few life
regrets okay my other life it's a good
lesson to learn and i think that's
definitely something that you'll take
with you like to your future children
and you'll instill in them and they will
be
so passionate about what they do one of
my other regrets um
is not getting into the cop car i think
i've shared that story a few times you
have
what are your some of your life's
biggest cigarettes my biggest life
regret was going on that teen tour
that summer um i just feel like i could
like that's literally my biggest regret
because everything else it's like yeah i
made mistakes but you know
you learned something yeah and so but
that like nothing was learned it was a
complete waste of like
what could have been a fabulous summer
for me i could have gone back to
fat camp i was a little chunky i could
have lost a few pounds and instead like
the whole trajectory of my life was just
off no it wasn't because you two you
took control you know what i would still
be sitting here if i didn't go on that
teen tour and that's why it's
it's um something that i regret right
because it's like
uh a summer of my life that was wasted
and i would still be who i am today
which i'm happy with but i would have
had a better summer
in the 11th grade and you know what at
that point in my life like i could have
really used a good summer right and
that's like that i was just like
another traumatic like hard friend
making experience
yeah that's the last thing i [ __ ]
needed well honestly that's another
thing you really learned growing up like
and i think carol radswell was trying to
tell us this like as a young fabulous
person you only have so many like
fabulous summers
especially like when you're in high
school like those summers are so
formative you have so many like first
time experiences your first kiss like
i just feel like i didn't take and i
used to love summer don't get me wrong
like i used to live
10 months for two but i feel like i just
took it for granted like those summers
just flew by and like those were like
some of the best summers of my life
yeah and i also think i think in high
school you do a good job of taking
advantage of the summer but
some people do start to feel pressure to
like do a program that's gonna
advance them to college or whatever like
no in high school
enjoy your summers they are meant just
to be pure fun and then also in college
you definitely want to make your spend
your summers intentionally get an
internship that will help get a job yeah
and it is really important
in like the job search to have had those
internships
but i do think that you should
prioritize your summers because you'll
never get those back unless you become a
teacher
which is a wonderful reason to become a
teacher i could not agree more of course
you should have other better motives
like wanting to help the youth but i
don't think it's bad to have
summers off on the top of your list
because i feel that wholeheartedly then
then kyle rodswell shouldn't become a
teacher because then she would have
an eternity of good summers left that's
not what she was saying about because
i know i know she meant like her age
yeah
and just like overall vivaciousness
i wonder how many summers she has left
her do you think she's done um
no i think she wound up having more
summers than she expected yeah
that's what happens when you date a
younger man or that's just like what
happens when you age with power
you can have as many summers as you want
so true okay you ready for our next
story it's a little satanic news
ooh satanic news nike
denies involvement nike oh you know
how you heard of nike you said it weird
roll it
roll the tape you guys everyone rewind
and let us know did i say it weird
you did you were like nine you said i
robbed
you so weird yeah wow you did
i won't forget this nike deny's
involvement with
lil nas x satan shoes containing human
blood
what yup i don't understand this whole
saga
nike is collaborating i'm sorry they
don't want they don't want to be
involved
scratch out start from beginning
you're having trouble with the story i
know there's so much at play yes and
it's
i think it's like the satanic-ness of
the story by the way
it's like i'm i'm i don't want the power
of the devil has entered your spirit
like that's what's happening also i
don't want to make jokes about the devil
because
as i'm learning from this little naz
controversy like you can't joke about
the devil i don't know much about like
the devil or satan because um we don't
have that in judaism but i'm just going
to stay out of this one
lil nas is collaborating with the
streetwear company
mschf on a pair of satan shoes only 666
pairs of which
went on sale on monday they did sell out
the controversial kicks which are
apparently modified nike air max 97s
are decorated with a pentagram pendant
and a reference to luke 10 18 a bible
verse about satan's fall from heaven
i wonder if carlton jebia got a pair the
sneakers also contain a drop of human
blood in the soul
of the shoe soul sole
drawn from members of the mschf team
the company told nbc news on sunday news
of the shoes drew
outrage over the palm sunday weekend
some critics slam both nil
lil nas and nike but nike was quick to
distance itself from the shoes
pointing out that their adaptations of
existing products they said we do not
have a relationship
with lil nas or mschf
nike did not design or release these
shoes and we do not endorse them
um so why do people think nike is a part
of this because it's a nike sneaker that
they redesigned
are you allowed to do that there's no
there's the check yeah so i think also
this is now going to become litigious
for nike for like reset like for
all of this but it's just like the
satanic element which really has
people all riled up i just can't believe
there's 666 people who
like would wait online and crave a pair
of shoes with a drop of human blood in
it but people are weird people
are weird and it's more than that
because they like sold out so quickly
right
i i'm good on the satanic elements
personally you know i
have enough devilish people in my life i
don't need to
harbor the spirit of the devil um but i
like that song
call me when you won call me when you uh
i don't know what he's actually saying
but i really like that song it's going
viral on tick tock it'll hit the radio
soon is that call me by your name
yes but it's call me oh maybe you're
saying call me by your name yeah the
song is called
montero call me by your name call me my
honey no that doesn't sound right i'm
pretty sure he's saying
call me what you won't but maybe he's
not and the music video
for the song is satanic as well um lil
nazis seemed
that he's seduced out of what appears
appears to be the garden of eden and
falls into hell and gives the devil a
lap dance and he takes a stripper pole
down to hell
and people are all outraged about it and
i don't know enough to like say
something but i thought it was funny
and um he's quite a good dancer very uh
limber
i didn't see that i didn't expect that
because you're always wearing clothes
that are quite restrictive you know like
those cowboy outfits like you can't
really move your arms
but he was wearing spandex and he really
laid it down
well that's the latest in devil worship
news you know we will keep you updated
on
all the news in the satanic world um
i was okay i was just about to make a
really bad joke i'm so glad i didn't
that's called growth okay ready for our
next story
yeah melissa rycroff reveals
former bachelorette revealed she was
turned down for real houses of dallas
twice
you know melissa reich says show me a
picture she's like former bachelorette
from like ten years ago oh
okay and she sometimes guess judges on
dcc making the team oh cool she's a
former dcc i believe now she lives in
dallas and they won't let her on the
show
why i don't know it kind of like makes
sense but i didn't know they had like
such a high
bar i would think that any like former
sort of famous influencer
person could get on if they wanted to i
find that so shocking
yeah she recently did a q a on instagram
someone asked would you why would you
never go on the real house size of
dallas
she said i've been interviewed and
turned down twice i am so
not housewife material well maybe it's
just that she really doesn't know any of
the women like that's a possibility i
have to be tied a little bit
melissa rycroft is the one who jason
mesnick like dumped for molly
oh so she didn't win no but she became
the bachelorette oh right right right so
she she could have been misses
the original ahri he was so messy um
okay got it thank you for explaining
that because i'm like i've literally
never heard of this girl in my life
um is she married to her partner from
the bachelor no
i don't think so i mean they have three
kids um
i just thought i think this is
interesting yeah no i have to look at
her page to see if she actually is
halfway housewife material because
it's not just being well known that
makes you a good housewife like you have
to be
stylish you have to be a little crazy
you have to have like something
interesting about your life like an
interesting husband or like a mom who's
crazy but i also think like
what you're up to in your life like
needs to coincide with what's going on
at the franchise currently and i don't
think
a former reality tv just like mom
blogger would really work with the
real housewives of dallas crew right now
right but i do think in other franchises
oh see like they could really benefit
from amazon sir
amanda adrina patridge one time was like
rumored to be on the show
i think that they could benefit from an
influence on their show so i think it
just depends on like
where they're at in the season of the
show but like right now real houses of
dallas
even though this season is like not its
best the cast is really
elevated elevated highland park you know
they're
they're
a serious bunch of women so and i also
think they
run in a very similar social circle
which is like a very elite society
dallas they know each other yes the show
they hang out off the show they're
invited to the same party so i think
that like in staying with that
they have a good mix of women yeah no
now
like now that i've thought it over she
makes sense to have auditioned and she
makes sense to have not gotten the gig
yeah but i think like if this was real
houses of salt lake city rach parcell
should get the gig
that like real housewives of salt lake
city is like an amazing show but the
only thing that it's missing
is rage parcel or a parcel scala
girl because then rach could like you
know maybe rage is too busy she's like
one thousand kids like
maybe rachel could just like pop in on
her sister's filming you know
i don't know i would take any of that
it's gotta be rage of course it has to
be rachel but i would really take any of
them i would take yeah they just have
such interesting lives or i would even
take the mom
like yeah yeah and then we can get all
of them yeah that's actually better
yeah that works um i agree some
franchises would really benefit from
like a digital personality
or like someone with like a big
following from a reality show and some
would not
and i agree dallas is a little too high
society for that
so i think they made the right decision
but i'm just i'm so interested
interviewed twice so they thought about
it and
they came to this conclusion yeah no and
she wants it bad
she does are ready for our next story
yes
it's a little fast food news that i
think that's the best type of
it's the best type of news and like
honestly the game is changing not on
passover though i'm so hungry
pizza hut is redesigning their
drive-through and i think like
it's they drive there was an amazing
drive through yeah and now they're gonna
have the hut lane
which will offer convenience and speed
without customers ever having to park
their cars it's to
minimize the human contact element
customers can place orders through the
pizza hat
pizza hut app website and the
restaurant's phone number through a new
lane and they will just be able to pick
up their feelings
i think that while the drive-through
lane is
nearly the present it's nearly perfect
like there are ways to modernize it and
bring it into the future
and i think that this could be like the
beginning obviously of a new chapter for
pizza hut but like for so many other
franchises
like that line shouldn't be that long no
i agree but at the same time like
some of that is unavoidable because yes
if you live near pizza and you're
getting pizza for your family for dinner
it's easy to place the order and then go
but most fast food
people are driving through it's just
like hey should we stop here you're not
planning it so you're not going to whip
out your app 10 minutes before
most of it is like roadside you're on a
drive on a road trip
so sometimes yes at a local pizza hut a
lot of people get pizza for their
families like for dinner
that i understand but all the times that
like we've ever had drive through it's
not like i'm never planning it
maybe once in a while but yeah but no i
know i'm gonna get mcdonald's like on
this three-hour road trip i don't know
which specific mcdonald's i'm gonna get
to
and when i'm 15 minutes away to put in
so this is good
they should they should keep both i
don't think the drive-thru is ever going
to go away because it's literally so
brilliant
it's so brilliant and so iconic i'm like
literally like
my mouth is watering from this
conversation but you can have french
fries why don't you get some french
fries today
i mean it's a french fries i guess i can
because you know i'm trying to be like
really k for p you know
french fries are the most cake for
people like they're not bread they can
be breaded like you don't know what's on
the outside
no no you know it's potato and oil you
know that
i'll think about it yeah no like that's
like one of the joys of passover our
french fries and cheese yes
chips chips chips cheeps love chips
are ready for our fifth and final story
wow that happens so fast sure
it's a little survey news that's showing
the preferences of people
okay the return of the dad bod a survey
finds people prefer
a softer male body type 75
one of those people 75 of respondents to
a survey conducted by dating.com said
that they preferred the body shape to a
more
toned one what's the website that did it
dating.com oh
the term dad bod was first popularized
in the mid-2010s to harshly critique the
beach bodies of actors like
leonardo dicaprio chris pratt and the
non-traditional hollywood physiques of
actors such as jason siegel and seth
rogen dating.com did a survey conducted
from 2000 participants
and found that 20 of participants
claimed that bad shape did not matter to
them at all
when it came to finding a partner it
also found that only 15 percent
liked a barbie or ken like body type
so very fitting and shaped bodies are
seen as ideal when it comes to
attracting a partner
however the users of dating.com just
prove that isn't always the case when it
comes to real-life romance i'm so glad
everyone's getting
on board movies and tv shows tend to
promote the idea of barbie and ken body
types
giving people the idea they need to look
similar in order to find their match
we are happy to confirm that is not how
the real world really
operates yeah because like okay yes it's
nice when someone's chiseled
when they're laying on top of you
they're hard like don't you want someone
soft and cuddly
yeah no and apparently they do no i'm so
glad that like we are changing the
stigma especially around
men yeah so i i think that was really
interesting 75 percent of surveys
of survey surveys services
of of servitude
of those surveys surveyed 75
of those surveyed yeah that's right
that's right said dad
check well i'm so glad to hear that i'm
definitely on board with that as well
and i'm so glad
i usually have like a lot of unpopular
opinions you know so now it's nice to
know like no i actually have a popular
you're in the majority
yeah like i'd like to wear my bra around
the house like other people don't like
i'm just like weird
i'm just just quirky and different so
quirky i'm not like other girls
um before we wrap up there was no tv on
yesterday but i did catch up on rupaul's
drag race
and they did one of my favorite episodes
which is the roast
challenge where like i always tell you
this and i never know if you're
listening but
when it comes to being like a perfect
director i'm always listening
when no with drag race like you do
sometimes tune me out like i could tell
literally never okay well so what does
that you projecting because that's what
you do when i talk about
like my passions okay so what
what is it what do i always say like it
takes to be like a real like the winner
okay obviously the glam has to be on
point but comedy too okay
you are listening so yeah you need to be
like a well-rounded queen and the roast
really separates the boys from the men
like
or the men from the women whatever um
because like you really need to
hold your own and like doing stand-up is
like so hard and so it's always my
favorite challenge because for me like i
always i'm drawn to like the funny
queens
so they always show up and show out
candy muse who is my favorite who's like
not a winner
finally won her first challenge because
she's so funny and i'm just so happy for
her
um then it was like all these fashion
queens like who are like
not funny like simone that's the one who
rihanna dm'd like who was like
definitely going to win like
she was in the bottom like she really
flopped like it was not good then gomek
who's a real fashion queen
who i'm obsessed with um she
she really killed it so i don't know it
was like kind of like an episode where
we re-evaluated like everything we
thought we knew
but basically this queen utica went home
and she's like quirky like and i don't
love the
quirky queens like crystal method from
last season like
i don't some people are drawn to quirky
queens like i'm drawn to like
plus size and funny queens like that's
who i'm drawn to but some people are
drawn to like they're
artists and they're just like weird and
quirky and utica was one of those
um queens and for some reason like and
she's like
super nice and she's very like they did
this challenge the doppelganger
challenge where they paired up
um queens and they had to make each
other look like each other and she was
like very very nervous
because she was paired with simone who's
black and she didn't want to you know
wear an afro she didn't want a cultural
appropriate so she's very
like sensitive to other people's
feelings and she's just like this really
sweet
sweet queen and then in the roast she
comes out
she calls everyone fat like she's being
insanely [ __ ] mean she calls michelle
visage old
she goes lonnie love that she says
lonnie love doesn't have a career
like she caught like it was just crazy
and i'm like unico
what are you doing utica went home
obviously
because she stunk but then also like
when you're in the bottom two you lip
sync for your life
and simone is just like oh wait better
lip syncer and it was it was utica's
time to go
but it was just like the craziest thing
like this this queen who was like
so like sensitive and like really
worried about like offending people
and i get that it's a roast but it was
the nice girl roast they roasted all the
miscongenialities for the last couple
years
so it was like you were supposed to be
nice um
it was just a nice was she funny no
that's the thing and that's what rupaul
said it's like
a roast like you can be mean but if you
are like it has to be
really funny like you just came out and
you were like observing things you're
fat you're old like
it was so weird and so it was her time
to go and now there's only five left
olivia locks has got to go you know this
time i feel like sometimes happens like
on other
shows like the bachelor like you know
when someone just like accidentally
makes it to the top five
yes olivia luck's had like two good
weeks olivia lux is not a winner she has
to go
rose got mick uh simone and candy muse
are
i think are gonna be the top four and
candy mews is definitely
not winning so i think got mick rose
like i
really did not like her rose is
saying what you want about her she's an
all-around queen she's singing she
dances she's hysterical she's got the
looks
rose could win i think of rose or gotmik
even though i love
simone she has just like i don't know
i don't know i'd be happy with any of
them that's a thing and i never i i've
never really had that before i'm always
like really gutting for one person i
would love candy muse to win but like
she's just not a winner like i know that
about her
so then between got mc rose and simone i
would be so happy if any of them win and
i really mean that
wow that's beautiful yeah so it's
actually been like one of the best
seasons like
ever and it's been covered like they
haven't been able to like they usually
have an audience for the roast
um and they usually bring in sometimes
they bring in like army vets and they do
like um
drag makeovers they bring in like you
know random people do drag makeovers
there's been none of that
but it's still been really good oh
that's great and they usually have the
best guest judges like the biggest stars
everyone's dying to be
right but they haven't they've had a few
in rotation who stay like lonnie love
has been on she usually would be on like
once a season now she's been on like
five times
yeah because they're keeping a few
people in rotation in the bubble in the
bubble and then just keeping like ross
matthews carson
and michelle visage um like they're the
state
they they always stay so i feel like
it's been a show that's been completely
unimpacted by covet and i've been like
so happy to have it back
and it's been one of my favorite seasons
it's been they just got like an amazing
group of queens like everyone is so
talented and
um they had like a few people like
coming remotely and hathaway came in
remotely just like give him a pep talk
and next week scarlett johansson's
coming in remotely but like who cares
damn unless colin jose makes an
appearance he might can't be bothered
well i'll be watching the other bowling
girl spoon speaking of
scarlett johansson is she in it yes she
plays mary boleyn
is that the other bowler and then ann
bolin is played by natalie portman i
don't know how we've never seen this
movie
yeah yeah i'm just like not a huge
natalie portman girl me neither but i
really should be because she's like our
jewish
queen yeah no i've never okay ready i've
never seen black squad
swan i think that movie with ashton
kutcher is just like a sad attempt at
being the mila kunis justin timberlake
movie
friends with benefits and it's just so
bad it's like we get it you're a doctor
you can still have a boyfriend i just
like hate movies with those like
oh i can't i have a boyfriend like
nobody cares um
and then like i don't even know what
else she's been in i'm just like not a
natalie portman girly whatsoever no
me neither and i don't think like that
would surprise anyone
no i know i just think she like takes
herself really seriously especially in
her films
and i like to watch fun films i agree i
love a fun film and then she's also
she's in like thor and star wars and
like a lot of superhero movies oh that's
why i don't watch that
oh and she was jackie jackie
husband oh i did see that movie and i
thought she was
terrible so i think that's confirmed i'm
just not a natalie portman girl like
no shade if you are like have so much
respect for you like live your life be
your best self
i just have personally made the choice
not to
live for natalie portman you all just
have to respect that
we do we really do um other than that i
think tonight i'm going to turn my tv on
for the first time in like something's
on tonight's
real housewives of dallas okay i have to
catch up on last week me too
and yeah we have got your toasters
tomorrow so excited get your little
quandaries into us at deertoasters
gmail.com so yeah we'll do dallas
recap tomorrow and your toaster so make
sure to write your toasters at gmail.com
and i cannot stress this enough if you
have written us in and we have
read your prompt on air please let us
know how when we are dying over here
send us an update email at deartoasters
gmail.com just put
update in the uh subject line or just
respond to the email
it would be really helpful for us
because we we're just trying to type
some loose ends
yeah for sure and if you're feeling rdh
that this episode is ending head over to
patreon.com
content and are lots of premium episodes
7.99 a month for five extra episodes
from jackie and i blogs and podcast
episodes great way to support the show
and get access to the last remaining
facebook group on earth the toast after
dark which is really one of the only
safe spaces on the internet
so it's a fabulous place it's worth the
seven dollars for that regardless yeah
anyways that's our show thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcast find
us morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow for
hump day